[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير اهلا بكم الى
نشره الخامسه من العربيه التي نستهلها
بابرزيل عناوين
يقول انه ليس متشددا العربيه
روسيا تكثف هجماتها للسيطره
من تفاقم الصراع بعد امداد كيف بصواريخ
بعيده المدى
البحريه الفرنسيه تصادم 5000 قطعه سلاح
ايرانيه كانت متجهه للحوت خلال اخر شهرين
في بريطانيا منذ عشر سنوات
اهلا بكم اعزائي المشاهدين قبل بدايه
النشره انقل اليكم هذه الصور مباشره من
مصر حيث دلع حريق منذ قليل في مستشفى
النور المحمدي الخيري بمنطقه المطريه في
القاهره كما نشاهد في هذه المشاهد وقد
اكدت قوات الحمايه المدنيه انتقال سيارات
الاسعاف والاطفاء لموقع الحريق الذي لم
يتم حتى الساعه معرفه الاسباب التي ادت
الى ذلك فيما اكدت همم المصادر ان عمليات
الاطفال مستمره لمحاوله السيطره على هذا
الحريق اذا الحريق في مستشفى النور
المحمدي بمنطقه المطريه في القاهره سنكون
بعد قليل مع مراسليننا همم في القاهره
لموافاتنا باي جديد حول هذا الحريق
كده نزل على المطافي
بعد اعلان طهران بالامس معرفتها بمصدر
المعدات المستخدمه في هجوم بطائرات مسيره
على منشاه عسكريه في مدينه اصفهان افاد
موقع نور نيوز المحسوب على السلطات ان
المعدات المستخدمه في هذا الهجوم دخلت
بامر من جهاز امني خارجي
وبمشاركه جماعات معارضه لطهران في اقليم
كردستان العراق
وقال الموقع ان اجزاء من الطائرات المسيره
والمواد المتفجره المستخدمه في الهجوم
دخلت ايران عن طريق شمال البلاد قبل ان
يتسلمها احد المتعاونين مع الجماعات
الكرديه في مدينه حدوديه
جهاز مكافحه الارهاب في اقليم كردستان
اعلن اليوم عن استهداف قاعده يزل كان
التركيه بثمانيه صواريخ وقد تبنى هذا
الاستهداف فصيل يسمى باحرار العراق وهو
فصيل يتبع لمليشيات الحشر هذا وتقيمه انقر
نحو 40 نقطه وقاعده عسكريه في شمال العراق
قرب حدودها حيث تطارد منذ اكثر من 25 عاما
مقاتلي حزب العمال الكردستاني الذي تصنفه
انقره وحلفائها الغربيون منظمه ارهابيه
العربيه تمكنت من الوصول الى مخابئ ومقار
واحد من اهم الاحزاب الايرانيه المعارضه
وهو الحزب الديمقراطي الكردستاني الايراني
وقد رصدت ما يجري داخل معسكره الذي يقع
على بعد كيلو متر واحد من الحدود
الايرانيه
[موسيقى]
معارضه كرديه
نحن اليوم في جبل حلقه اولى وسيله اعلاميه
تصل الى معسكر تابعه في هذا الجبل على بعد
كيلو متر واحد من الحدود الايرانيه
[موسيقى]
بالك الرساله العراق يتحسن مقاتلون محاربه
الايرانيه لكنها لا تحجب رؤيه النظام
مرحبا
الديمقراطي الكردستاني الايراني
[تصفيق]
مع السلامه
النظام الايراني على مواقع الحزب في نمر
الماضي
حاول النظام تقويدا الانتفاضه المدنيه عبر
جرنا الى صراع عسكري
كان الحزب الديمقراطيه كردستانيه الايراني
حجر اساسي اول دوله كرديه في مها بعد
الايرانيه عام
1940 قبل ان تسقط ليعد الحزب لن مشاركه في
الثوره الايرانيه ضد الشاه لم تنتهي القصه
هنا طويت صفحه الشاه وفتحت صفحه الخميني
عام
1979 فتوى ضد من سماهم بالمتمردين الاكراد
وكان يقصد حينها الاحزاب الكرديه
الايرانيه المعارضه التي طالب
بالديمقراطيه والحكم الذاتي منذ ذلك الحين
بدات هذه الاحزاب صراعا مع السلطه صراع
دفع بعضهم الى مغادره البلاد واقامه
معسكرات في كردستان العراق
للاحزاب الكرديه الايرانيه هنا مكاتب
ومقرات تنشط فيها سياسيه كما لها مخابئ
ومواقع للتدريب على السراحه ان كانت تشدد
على ان المواجهه المسلحه مع النظام مؤجله
للاهلي
طبعا امل ولا اجبر على استخدام السلاح
ولكن اذا اضطرنا الى ذلك فسنستخدم الاسلحه
ليس فقط ضد الحارس الثوري الايراني ولكن
ضد اي شخص يريد سلبي حريتنا
[موسيقى]
الحدود العراقيه الايرانيه
قال مصطفى هجري زعيم الحزب الديمقراطي
الكردستاني الايراني المعارض والمطلوب
الاول النظام ان طهران تتهم وحزبه بارسال
اسلحه الى داخل ايران الامر الذي نفاه
متحدثا عن مواجهه المتظاهرين لقوات الامن
بايديهم العاريه
جمهوريه ايران الاسلاميه ردا على اي
احتجاج من قبل الشعب الايراني حتى
الاحتجاجات التي اعاقبت القتل الوحشي
لامراه بسبب عدم ارتدائعها حجاب الراس
بشكل مناسب يتهم النظام الجميع بانهم
عملاء للاجانب وانهم اعداء الاسلام يتهم
النظام حزبنا بارسال اسلحه الى داخله
ايران في الواقع يقف الشعب ضد قوات امن
النظام بايديهم العاريه
لو هيوندايزر مصطفى هجري اكد ايضا ان حزبه
يمتلك قوات من البشمركه لكنهم لا يخططون
لنشرها في ايران او استخدام الاسلحه في
المستقبل القريب ضد النظام لما
لدينا قوات بشمركه يتم تدريبها لكننا لا
نخطط لنشرها في ايران بدلا من ذلك نحاول
مساعده الاحتجاجات المدنيه وان نكون صوتهم
في وسائل الاعلام الدوليه للتواصل مع
الامريكيين والاوروبيين والدعوه لمطالب
الشعب الايراني للشعب قضيه عادله ويجبوا
تلبيه مطالبهم لذلك ليس لدينا خطه
لاستخدام الاسلحه في المستقبل القريب نامل
على ان الجمهوريه الاسلاميه سوف تسقط مع
الاحتجاجات المدنيه الحاليه
معي من بغداد الان يزيد من المتابعه
والتحليل المحلل السياسي نجم القصاب استاذ
نجم اهلا وسهلا بك الى نشاط الخامس من
العربيه طهران تؤكد ان المعدات المستخدمه
في الهجوم على احدى منشاتها العسكريه في
اصفهان تمت بواسطه الحزب الديمقراطي
الكردستاني الايراني المعارض ومقره اقليم
كردستان العراق وانها سترون الحزب ينفي
ذلك اين الحقيقه
تحيه لك ولكل متابعي كل الكرام يعني حسب
ما
موجود من معلومات وتسريبات واحاديث بان من
قام بهذه العمليه هي اسرائيل
والحزب العمال هو مصنف من ضمن
الفصائل او الاصناف الارهابيه التي تهدد
الدول المجاوره للعراق وحتى تواجد في
اراضي العراقيه حقيقه هي فتنه واحراج
لحكومه بغداد ولحكومه تقليم كردستان حتى
الانوا دافع على هذا الحزب الذي تستغله
تركيا طيله السنوات الماضيه
لدخول الجيش التركي وقصف المناطق العراقيه
خصوصا مناطق في اقليم كردستان بحجج وهي
بان تواجد هذا الحزب هو يهدد الحكومه
التركيه بنفس الوقت
بكى حينما يستخدم او يقوم باي عمليات كانت
سواء في الاراضي التركيه او الايرانيه
تبناها حتى على الاقل يحصل دعما او يحصل
على معنويات عاليه له
وللمقاتليه الذين الغير متواجدين في
الاراضي العراقيه بالتالي الى هذه الدقيقه
ليس هناك اثباتات بان هذا الحديث النبي
نحن يعني دائما دائما هنالك دائره مفرغه
همم
الحزب الديمقراطي الكردستاني الايراني
المعارض ما قررته معروفه يعني في شمال
العراق تحديدا في كردستان حتى مراسلتنا
اليوم دخلت الى عدد من المقرات السريه
لهذا الحزب وهو ح- ح- حزب عسكري يعني
مدجاج بالسلاح ايران تقول انه اراضي شمال
العراق تحولت الى منصه لشن الهجمات عليه
في حال الان اييه ردت ايران بالطبع بغداد
ستعتبر ذلك انتهاكا للسياده العراقيه
وبالتالي ستتقدم بشكاوه ولكن كيف يمكن حل
هذه المعظم المعضله هل فعلا تحول شمال
العراق كردستان العراق الى منصه للهجوم
على ايران املا هذا الكلام غير صحيح
يعني اولا الحل الامثل ان يكون هناك توحيد
في الخطابين السياسي والاعلامي من كل
القوه السياسيه
خصوصا بين الحكوميتين اقليم كردستان
وبغداد رغم الايام الماضيه كان هناك
اختلاف او خلاف او اللي ربما عاده انعدام
الثقه مثل ما كانت في الحكومات السابقه
خصوصا الحكومات قبل
2020 همم الامر الاخر اعتقد ايران هي
تجاوزت واعتدت على السياده العراقيه في
الاشهر الماضيه وحتى الحكومه التركيه كانت
وما زالت تعتدي على الاراضي العراقيه الحل
الامثال توحيد في الخطاب الاعلامي
والسياسي وعدم السماح لاي دوله كانت مسلمه
او غير مسلمه
بخرق هذه السياده العراقي لكن تعلم
المشاكل والخلافات والاختلافات وبين القوه
السياسيه تحاول لربما استغلال او السماح
لهذه بالاعتداء على العراق
يعطي وجود تشكيلات مسلحه في اقليم كردستان
ذريعه سواء لتركيا او لايران لشن مثل هكذا
هجمات او عمليات تواجد
بالتاكيد هذا ما تحدث فيه انا في سؤالك
الاول جاوبتك بان تواجد اي حركه او اي حزب
حقيقه يثير الجدل او شكوك او يهدد دوله
مجاوره مهما تكون علاقتنا طيبه مو طيبه
بالتالي لا ينبغي على الحكومه المركزيه
وعلى حكومه تقليم كردستان عدم السماح لاي
حزب اركان بالتالي العراق لا يحتاج الى
مشاكل وازمات الان مشكلته الدولارات في
العراق اصبحت مشكله كبيره متحدي كبير
للدوله العراقيه وليس له حكومه السيد
السودان فقط بالتالي نحن العراقي ينبغي
علينا الابتعاد على هذه الصراعات وعلى هذه
المشاكل خصوصا تواجد هذه الاحزاب في
الاراضي العراقيه وحصرا في اراضي اقليم
كردستان من بغداد المحلل السياسي نجم
القصاب شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه
النشاط الخامس مستمره فيها ايضا
الليره اللبنانيه تفقد 90% من قيمتها
الرسميه بقرار البنك المركزي الذي تبنى
سعر صرف 15000 ليره للدولار الواحد
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم جديد الى نشره الخامسه من
العربيه اعتادت القوات الروسيه امطار
المناطق المستهدفه باوكرانيا بنيران كثيفه
وبالتحديد الصاروخيه منها قبل محاوله
اقتحامها لكن الوضع تغير في بخمت محللون
لصحيفه نيويورك تايمز الامريكيه قالوا ان
التكتيكا في بخم التغير نحو دفع موجات
هائله من المقاتلين لاقتحام خطوط الدفاع
الاوكرانيه وهو امر يقلق كاف
وبحسب الاوكرانيين للصحيفه فان الخسائر
الروسيه في القتال الاخير في باخ موت كانت
اعلى مما كانت عليه في الاشهر السابع حيث
دفع القاده الروس بالجنود الى المعركه
المحللون التبروا ان المعركه الضاري حول
بخم تشير ايضا الى ان اوكرانيا يتغلبت على
مخاوفها بشان الانخراط مباشره في معركه
مطوله من اجل مدينه واحده وان كتاب مستعده
لتحمل الخسائر على امل ان تتمكن من
استنزاف القوات الروسيه اكثر
فمحللين عسكريين
فان القيمه الاستراتيجيه لبخموت هي كونها
مفترق الطرق لبعض الطرق السريعه في تلك
المنطقه
في مقابل ذلك قال الكريملين ان الصواريخ
طويله المدى التي قيل انها ضمن حزمه مقبله
من المساعدات العسكريه الامريكيه
لاوكرانيا ستفاقم الصراع لكنها لن تمنع
روسيا من تحقيق اهدافها
واضاف الكرملين ان الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين ليس لديه اي خطط لعقد محادثات مع
نظيره الامريكي
في الوقت الحالي
نائب المستشار الالماني روبرت قال من جهته
ان تزويد اوكرانيا بطائرات مقاتله سيكون
امرا خاطئا واعتبر في مقابله تلفزيونيه
انه ليس من الصواب توريد مقاتلات الان
وردا على سؤال من احد الصحافيين في توضيح
ما اذا كان ذلك الان فقط او بشكل عام اوضح
نائب المستشار الالماني انه بشكل عام فان
ذلك لا يعتبر صحيحا
رئيس الاستخبارات العسكريه الروسيه
سارجينا رش كين قال ان حلفنيته يزيد
الرهان في اوكرانيا لانه مازال يحلم
بهزيمه روسيا استراتيجيه وان احلامه هذه
لن تتحقق
وانتقد واشنطن الاخيره لكيف بتقديم مزيد
من المساعدات العسكريه لها فيما اكد رئيس
اللجنه العسكريه
ان اهدافها موسكو الاستراتيجيه تتخطى فضاء
اوكرا
بيبو
المزيد من المتابعه
مراسله العربيه
رائد الاكبر رائد دعني ابدا معك لو سمحت
هل لديك تاكيدات من ان بخمط محاصره تماما
كما تقول السلطات الروسيه وان مساله
سقوطها هي مساله ايام قليله
املا الامور غير واضحه
يعني طالب الحديث عن باقي متو تطويق مدينه
باخمط هو معلن منذ يعني حوالي شهر او اكثر
كانت القوات الروسيه او قوات فاجنر تحديدا
تحاول تطويق المدينه من الناحيه الجنوبيه
والشرقيه وكانت مستعصيه عليهم مدينه
سوليدار بعد السيطره على سوليدار اصبحت
مدينه يعني مدينه باخمه مطوقه من ثلاث
نواحي الجنوبيه والشماليه والشرقيه لكن
الدفاع الروسيه وموسكو وعلى لسان الرئيس
الروسي بلادي مير بوتن قال لا يجب ان
نتعجل
باعلام السيطره على اي منطقه فاليوم اعلان
ااه السيطره من قبل السلطات المحليه وربما
من الدفاع الروسيه على كان مرتبطا بقطع
الامدادات التي تصل للمقاتلين داخل مدينه
باخم من مدينتي كاستنطينه ومن مدينه ايضا
همم
هاتان المدينه
تفصلهما طرق يعني مع المقاتلين داخل ضخمه
كانت يعني الامدادات العسكريه البشريه
وبالعتاد تصل بشكل يومي اعلنت القوات
المسلحه هنا عن قطع الطريق عن همم
شسوفيار والسيطره على طريق قسطنطينيه وهو
الذي دفع السلطات للاعلان عن السيطره على
المدينه لكن التطويق ما زال مستمر الحديث
عن تحصينات قويه عند الجيش الاوكراني
القتال الشوارع هو في المحور الجنوبي اا
بعد الانطلاق من منطقه كلاشينك همم الوصول
الى ايفانوكا وهي بالعمق الجنوبي من
المدينه هناك قتال شوارع بالفعل لكن ليس
هناك اي حديث عن سيطره كامله سوى عن
التطويق والتطويق وحاصل منذ سابق لكن ربما
اضيفنا وبعجا لان القوات الروسيه تتقدم من
المحور الشمالي بالناحيه العكسيه بعد
سوليدار تتقدم نحو
وسيطرت على عده بلدات في ذلك المحور من
اجل اكمال الطوق وقطع الامدادات عن كل
المنافذ التي تصل الى مدينه باخم طيب رائد
يبقى معي سنتقل الى كاتيا في موسكو كاتيا
اخر الاخبار والمواقف سواء من الكرملين او
من وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ما يتعلق بمعركه
باخموت او موضوع ارسال صواريخ غربيه بعيده
المدى لك اياها
من موضوع ارسال امريكا او القوات الحلف
النيته المزيد من الاسلحه وطبعا القرار
الامريكي حول ارسال صواريخ بعيده المدى
علق عليه الكريم لانها فقد سيزيد من
التوتر والتصعيد ولكنه لين يغير شيئا على
الارض رئيس الاستخبارات
الخارجيه الروسيه
الى زياده وتوسيع يعني نطاق الاسلحه التي
تصل الى اوكرانيا من اجل همم
الفوز على روسيا ولكن هذا الشيء لن يحدث
كما قال هو فقط محاوله
لهزيمه لروسيا حتى اخر اوكراني طبعا كانت
رئيسه مجلس الاتحاد اليوم كانت قد تحدثت
المتحده ان ارادت همم ان تنهي هذا الصراع
كانت قد ارغب متى اوكرانيا الجلوس الى
طاوله المحادثات وهي لا ترغب بذلك كما
قالت ان روسيا هي مستعده قد ان تجري او
تجلس الى طاوله المحادثات مع اوكرانيا ان
رغبت الاخرى طبعا في ذلك ولكن هذا شيء لا
لا يوجد لدى الجانب هذه الرغبه جانب
الاوكراني بانتجه الى تجلس الى طالب
الطاوله المحادثات مع اجانب الروسي لذلك
كما يقول الكريمان والسبطات الروسيه تقول
ان العمليه العسكريه روسيه ستستمر حتى
نهايه همم او تحقيق جميع الاهداف التي
وضعتها روسيا واي شحنه جديده سواء كانت من
الدبابات او من الاسلحه التي تصل من غير
ستكون هدفا شرعيا دائما للقوات الروسيه
طالب قبل ان انتقل الى رائد اكثر من
مسؤوله اوكراني عسكري اليوم تحدث انه
لديهم معلومات موثوقه من ان موسكو تحضر
لهجوم واسع النطاق من ثلاثه محاور وان
المساله مساله اسابيع هل فعلا تتحضر موسكو
لمثل هكذا هجوم واسع النطاق همم كاتيا وفق
المعلومات المتواتر ام لا هذا الموقف فقط
من اكياس لاسباب تتعلق بكيف
حقيقه طالب هي توقعات كانت تحدثت عنها
تقارير اعلاميه وكانت اغلبته اغلبها اما
اوكرانيه او غربيه بان روسيا ستبدا الان
قبيل حتى الربيع بشان هجوم مكثف على
اوكرانيا ومن خلال جهات طبعا من الشمال من
بلا روسيا ومن دونيسكو لوكاسكو من الجنوب
من البحر الاسود وهذا روسيا طبعا لم تؤكده
او لم ااه نفتهم مرارا ان روسيا لن تقوم
بشوب من الشمال من جانب بيلاروسيا لذلك هي
حتى الان فقط تبقى تقارير اعلاميه او
تقارير خبراء عسكريين لا اكثر حتى الان لا
يوجد اي تاكيدات ولكن هناك توقعات كما
ذكرت من قبل الخبراء ان يكون قبيل ان تصل
الشحنات الغربيه الجديده الى اوكرانيا بان
يكون هناك هجوم مكثف على همم على اوكرانيا
طبعا تعليقا ايضا على موضوع بحث اليوم كان
هناك حديث القوات الانفصاليه بانه تمت
محاصره هذه المدينه همم بدعم من قوات راكن
الخاصه من القوات الروسيه تمت محاطه هذه
المدينه مثل جهاد في اطار التقدم الاخير
الذي نشهده بالقوات الروسيه على الارض
هناك طالب رائد السؤال ايضا مواجه لك ولكن
بطريقه اخرى هل يعني وفق ما ترى خصوصا
معطيات الميدانيه التي بين يديك هل موسكو
تسابق الوقت تستعجل الوقت لشن هذا الهجوم
الذي تتحدث عنه كيف قبل وصول الاسلحه
الغربيه الى القوات الاوكرانيه هل هنالك
معطيات معطيات ميدانيه تؤكد ذلك
بالضبط طالب بالضبط يعني القوات الروسيه
منذ اعلان التجزئه التعبئه الجزئيه في
سبتمبر العام الماضي وصلت بعدها اعداد
كبيره وارتال عسكريه من الجنود هناك ايضا
ادخال لمقاتلات روسيه حديثه ودبابات حديثه
منذ مطلع هذا العام في العمليات العسكريه
في نطاق العمليات العسكريه تتقدم القوات
الروسيه وهنا كثافه بالجنود وبالاليات في
جميع المحاور اهمها المحور الشرقي هنا حيث
نرى التقدم ليس على محور باقي مت على سبيل
المثالدار لم تشهد المدينه اي تقدم من قبل
القوات الروسيه عندما بات هنا يعني مزيد
من الاعداد العسكريه الجنود الروس دفعت
القوات الروسيه بمجموعات وفرق لتطويق
مدينه اوغدار التي تشهد في هذه الايام
عمليات عسكريه كبيره وتطويق من قبل الجيش
الروسي وقصب المدافع وبالصواريخ من المحور
الجنوبي والمحور الشرقي قالت السلطات
المحليه هنا بان محور هو اهم محور
بالتوازي مع باق مت لكن هناك تحصينات
كبيره عند الجانب الاوكراني داخل العباره
عن السراديب والانفاق اضافه الى اعداد
كبيره من الدبابات الاليات العسكريه التي
يتمتع بها الجانب الاخراني داخل المدينه
لان الامدادات مفتوحه
على كل هذه المعلومات ايضا شكرا لك يا
كاتيا طبعا من مراسله العربيه كانت معي من
موسكو
نقل صحيفه عن مصادر مطلعه قولها انا
البحريه الفرنسيه صادرت اسلحه ايرانيه
كانت متجهه الى الحوثي في اليمن
كانت ايران تنقلها للحوثي ويبلغ عددها 20
صاروخ ونقلت الصحيفه عن مسؤولين قولهم ان
باريس صادرت 3000 بندقيه ايرانيه ونصف
مليون طلقه كانت في طريقها الى الحوثي
وقالت الصحيفه ان العمليه الفرنسيه ضد
الحوثي هي ضمن مخطط لاحتواء انشطه ايران
واشارت الى مصادره واشنطن لخمسه الاف قطعه
سلاح ايرانيه كانت متجهه للحوثي خلال اخر
شهرين
من جهه اخرى افاده مصدر دبلوماسي فرنسي
للعربيه ان فرنسا ستواصل تحمل مسؤولياتها
للتشجيع على حوار اقليمي متعدد الاطراف
كما قال المسؤول الفرنسي الكبير ان
التهديد الايراني بدا يمس اراضي اوروبا
وامن الاوروبيه مرجعا احد اسباب عدم
الاستقرار في المنطقه الى وجود الترسانه
الصاروخيه والمسيرات لدى ايران وان
المسيرات الايرانيه تشارك فيها هجمات
روسيه ما يشكل جرائم حرب في اوكرانيا اما
بالنسبه لزياره الخارجيه كاترين كولونا
الى السعوديه همم فلها طابع سياسيه على حد
قوله وان التعاون الثقفي سيكون في صبيا
المزيد من المتابعه حول هذا الموضوع معي
من باريس الان مراسل العربيه سوف يدق نادر
حسين اهلا وسهلا بك اولا ما الذي يستبطله
هذا الكلام للمسؤول الفرنسي الكبير الذي
تحدث اليك من ان باريس تواصل تحمل
مسؤولياتها لتشجيع اولا الاطراف على حوار
الاقليميه اي عن اي حوار اقليمي نتحدث ومن
هي هذه الاطراف
في الواقع المسؤول الفرنسي الرفيع المستوى
كان يتحدث الى مجموعه محدوده جدا من
الصحفيين كنا من بينهم وقد طرحنا عليه
السؤال جاء جوابه كما اذعت في مقدمه الخبر
طبعا بالنسبه للمحادثات الاقليميه
المحادثات المتعدده الاطراف كان المسؤول
الفرنسي يقصد ما رعدته فرنسا من خلال نسخه
بغداد الاولى مؤتمر بغداد الاولى التي
عقدت عام 2001 مؤتمر بغداد ثم النسخه التي
عقدت في عمان والتي سميت ببغداد اثنين
كانت فرنسا شاركت في ترقس المؤتمر الاول
في بغداد والمؤتمر الثاني الذي عقد في
عمان اكد المسؤول الفرنسي ان بلاده ستواصل
لاعب هذا الدور الدور الحوار بين اطراف
المتعدده وايضا تشجع على محادثات ثنائيه
بين اطراف لا تربطها علاقات جيده لكن ما
كان لافتا في كلام المسؤول الفرنسي هو
تصعيد اللهجه بشكل كبير اتجاه ايران عندما
قال حرفيا ان هذا البلد يلعب ادوار خبيثه
في المنطقه وفي العالم وهنا اقول لشركائنا
في الرياض وغيرهم من الشركاء ان فرنسا
ستقف الى جانبهم وستدعمهم وقد اظهرت لهم
ذلك في السابق ومستعد الان لتعزيز الشراكه
معهم ان ايران تواصل لاعبه دور مزازها
للاستقرار في المنطقه مباشره او عبر
وكلاءها وال- عامل عدم الاستقرار معروف
سببه ترسانه الصواريخ الايرانيه ولكن ايضا
المسيرات هذه المسيارات لا تستخدمها ايران
فقط في المنطقه انما بات ترسلها ترسلها
الى روسيا لتارك فيها جمال جرائم حرب على
اراضي اوروبا التهديد الايراني بدا يشمل
اذا اراضي الاوروبيين وامن الاوروبيين كما
قال هذا المتحدثنا هذا الكلام حسين على ما
قام به البرلمان الاوروبي ااا منذ اسبوعين
برفع توصيه بتصنيف الحارس الثوري كمنظمه
ارهابيه في اوروبا هل هذا يشجع الاتحاد
للمضي قدما في هذا القرار املا لا علاقه
لهذا بذلك
في الواقع فيما يتعلق
بتوجه الاوروبيين اللي وضع الحرس الثوري
الايراني على قائمه المنظمات ارهابيه هذا
الموضوع يسيروا طبعا دعاما من جانب بعض
الدول
اكدت دعم هذا التوجه ولكن فرنسا تحديدا
ورغم سوء علاقاتها بايران في الفتره
الاخيره الى حد كبير لكنها تخشى الذهاب
الى ابعد من التصعيد الكلام اللي عده
اسباب على راسها خشيتها على مصير الموقفين
الفرنسيين لدى ايران وعددهم سبعه وهو اكبر
عدد لموقفنا غربيين لدى ايران تصدر فرنسا
عدم وصول التصعيد الى هذا الحد وتتريح قبل
ان تدعم علنا وضع الحدث الثوري على قائمه
المنظمات الارهابيه عندما طرحت السؤال قبل
ايام على مسؤول فرنسي جاء الجواب ان فرنسا
ودول الاتحاد الاخرى تنتظر مشوره قضائيه
سيقدمها خلال ايام جوزيف بوريل المسؤول عن
السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي
اسباب كثيره لتوتر العلاقات بين باريس
وطهران لكن فرنسا لن تذهب الى حد التاييد
العلني لوضع الحرس الثوري على قائمه
المنظمات الارهابيه لدى الاتحاد الاوروبي
طالب من باريس مراسل العربيه سيفر شكرا
جزيلا لك حسين على كل هذه المتابعه
كشف تقرير لصحيفه ولست جورنال بان شكلا
جديدا للعصيان المدني ظهر بشكل لافت في
شوارع العاصمه طهران يتمثل بخروج اعداد
كبيره من النساء الايرانيات دون ارتداء
الحجاب الالزامي
في ايران التمرد الشعبي وضد النظام لم
يتوقف يوما وانقلت الاحتجاجات المنظمه او
اعداد حشود المتظاهرين وحتى تجمعات الطلاب
الا ان غضب الشارع الايراني الذي اشتعل
منذ سبتمبر الماضي لم يهدا لحظه شكل جديد
للاحتجاجات تشهدها شوارع طهران تقف وراءها
النساء الالاف من الايرانيات في طهران
يمشينا اليوم في الهواء الطلق دون ارتداء
الحجاب الالزامي شكل من اشكال العصيان
المدني من غير المرجح ان يطيح بالنظام
ولكن يقول الكثيرون بانه سيكون من الصعب
احتوائه في المستقبل وفق تقرير
السلطات في ايران حاولت قمع هذا السلوك
الجديد وامرت الشرطه بفرض غرامات على
النساء اللواتي يخالفن قواعد اللبس وكذلك
فرض عقوبات على سيارات الاجره والمطاعم
التي تسمح بالدخول دون حجاب خطوه لم تؤثر
على قرار الايرانيات فتجربه الاشهر
الماضيه كانت بالنسبه لهن نقطه لا عوده
كذلك الى غضب الايرانيين الذي لا يزال
يتصاعد مع رفض النظام الاستجابه الى
مطالبه ما يشير الى ان الاحتجاجات قد
تندلع مجددا في اي لحظه قريبه وبشكل
الاقوى وانف ربما خاصه في ظل زياده لتضخم
وهبوط العمله الايرانيه ما ادى الى تفاقم
الازمه الاقتصاديه يوما بعد يومين ملوك
الشيخ العربي
اعلن رئيس الوزراء العراقي محمد
عراقيين رفيع المستوى برئاسه وزير
الخارجيه سيزور واشنطن قريبا لمناقشه
التقلبات سعر الدولار واضاف في مقابله مع
قناه الاخباريه العراقيه ان الاجراءات
التي تقوم بها الحكومه ضمن النظام المصرفي
هي الاصلاح الحقيقي للنظام المصري وهي
الاجراءات التي ستحمي المال العام من
الطبيب
رئاسه وزير الخارجيه عضويه محافظ البنك
المركزي
المستشارين وكلاء راح يزور واشنطن يوم 7 2
في اكثر من ملف احد هذه الملفات التي سوف
تقضي على النقاش مع الخزانه الامريكيه
والفيدرالي هو موضوع الثقل
عليه
الجديد الجديده
نوع من الاجراءات الموجعه تسببت قلق لكنه
الاصلاح الحقيقي للنظام المصرفي للنظام
الاقتصادي للحفاظ على المال العام ومنعه
من التهريب وغسيل الاموال
لوكاله رويترز ان لبنان سيرفع سعر صرف
الدولار مقابل الليره اللبنانيه من
1570 ليرات الى خمسه عشر الف ليره ابتداء
من اليوم الاول من فبراير سلامه اكد ان
المصارف ستمنح خمس سنوات لاعاده تعويض
الخسائر الناجمه عن تخفيض قيمه العمله
وتاتي هذه الخطوه ضمن عمليه لتوحيد نظام
السعر الصرف المتعدد في البلاد نتيجه
الازمه الماليه التي يشهدها لبنان منذ
خريف عام 2019 بعد ان خسرت العمله
اللبنانيه اكثر من 95% من قيمتها حيث يصل
سعر الصرف في السوق الموازيه الى نحو 60
الف ليره للدولار الواحد بعد ان تخطى
الاسبوع الماضي عتبه 62 الفا
نشاطنا مستمره فيها ايضا
فيضانات غير مسبوقه تغرق شوارع اكلاند
اكبر مدينه نيوزلانديه
اهلا بكم جديد حوالي نصف مليون موظف وعامل
في قطاعات التعليم والنقل والخدمه المدنيه
اضرب في بريطانيا اليوم وذلك للمطالبه
بزياده الاجور وتحسين شروط العمل بعد فشل
المفاوضات مع الحكومه التي اكدت مرارا عدم
قدرتها على سداد اي زياده تفوق نسبه
التضخم المسجله التي تفوق العشره في المئه
عروض عبد الحق والتفاصيل
النقابات هددت اليوم كفي بوعودها في
التصعيد الاقصى بوتيره الاضطرابات هؤلاء
المضربون يبداون بما سيره من هذا المكان
حتى مقر الحكومه في تن داونز ستريت هؤلاء
من بين النصف مليون من العمال والموظفين
الذين يضربون عبر مختلف القطاعات والدوائر
الحكوميه هنا في بريطانيا يقولون ساعات
عمل طويله ورواتب بالكاد تكفي همم طبعا
جعلت العديد منهم عشرات الالاف يعتمدون
على بنوك الطعام بسبب عجل عن تحمل تكاليف
المعيشه في بريطانيا الحكومه ببساطه تقول
ان لا ما لديها لتحقيق مطالبهم برفع
الاجور تقول ان الحلب عبر التفاوض وليس
عبر الاضراب بل انها تذهب يعني باتجاه
تمرير مشروع قانون وذلك للحد من تحركات
نقابات العماليه وحتى هل هذا الخلاف بين
الحكومه والنقابات ستواجه بريطانيا المزيد
الاضرابات خلال الاسابيع والاشهر القليله
المقبله اليوم اضراب موظفي الخدمه المدنيه
والنقل والمعلمين ولكن الاسبوع القادم
سيكون اضراب الاسعاف والممرضين ما يعني
زياده الضغط على النقابات او زياده الضغط
على قطاع الصحه في بريطانيا الذي يعاني
بالاساس من لندن عروب عبد الحق العربيه
الى لندن لمزيد من المتابعه حول هذا
الموضوع مراسل العربيه مصطفى زارو تابع
هذا الاضراب مصطفى اهلا وسهلا بك جديد
المشهد اللندني والى اي مدى كان هذا
الاضراب شاملا عاما ناجحا ام لا كان
محدودا الى حد كبير
في الحقيقه طالب هناك الكثير من الملايين
من من تاثروا بهذا الاضراب الضخم الذي
شهدته البلاد وخاصه في انجلترا وويلز في
انجلترا وويلز بسبب
الاضراب الذي اقدم عليه عمال سكه الحديد
وخاصه سائقوا القطارات هناك ما يقارب من
نصف الشركات المشغله القطارات لم تعمل
اليوم بسبب اضراب هؤلاء السائقين بالاضافه
الى 100,000 موظف مدني همم العديد منهم
يعملون لصالح الحكومه مثلا بالنسبه لمصلحه
الضرائب كان هناك اضراب وهذه رساله قويه
للحكومه التي تتمسك بان همم ترفع الاجور
بنسبه التضخم وتقول بان اولويات الحكومه
حاليا وهو السيطره على التضخم الى النصف
تقول الحكومه بنها يعني بنهايه هذه السنه
ما سيساعد على مواجهه تكلفه المعيشه وقد
قدمت همم بحسب بعض القطاعات ما بين اربعه
فاصله خمسه الى تسعه في المئه من الزيادات
لهؤلاء المدربين ولكن هناك تعنت وهناك
مواصله هؤلاء الذين يقولون بانه يجب
الاضراب وانت تتوسع هذه الاضرابات ولا
ربما المزيد منها سيكون في همم يعني
الاسبوع المقبل مما سيكون له اثر ربما
اضخم مما شاهدناه اليوم مصطفى هل ستدفع
همم ستدفع هذه الاضطرابات وهذه الاحتجاجات
حكومه ريشي سوناك لتغيير سياساتها
ومواقفها ام لا يعني لا شيء سيتغير خصوصا
اذا ما اخذنا الاعتبار ما سمعناه منذ قليل
على لسان ريشه هناك في حديثه الى المعارضه
ما يمكن فهمه من تعامل الحكومات بانها
حقيقه تريد ان تتفاوض مع النقابات
المضربين ولكن هناك خطوط حمراء يجب ان لا
يتم تجاوزها خاصه في ما يتعلق برفع الاجور
بنسبه كبيره بما سيزيد الضغط على الخزانه
الماليه وايضا على عامه الناس خاصه بانه
همم نسبه تضخم هي همم يعني الخطر الكبير
على همم تكاليف المعيشه وايضا على اسعار
المنتجات الاساسيه التي يعتمد عليها همم
في المملكه المتحده بالطبع همم هذا الضغط
سيستمر ولكن اذا ما استمر مثلا حزب همم
العمال المعارض في تمسكه وانتقاده للحكومه
بشان تصرفاتها وتعملها مع المدربين فهذا
ربما يعيد الحكومه مراجعه سياستها وخاصه
هناك يقول مصطفى على المعارضه ان تخرج
تقول ان تنفيذ الاضرابات امر خاطئ واعطينا
اعلى زياده في الاجور لمده 30 عام هذا
يعني انه لاعب كل واحد متماثرش حول موقفه
وان الامور في الايام المقبله ذاهبه نحو
صدام اكبر
يعني الحكم المتمسكه بان تزيد او ترفع
الاجور بنسبه التضخم ولكن اذا ما استمر
الاضراب في التوسع يعني حاليا مثلا يعني
ما يقرب من نصف مليون لربما مثلا اذا ما
تم توسيع هذه الاضرابته تشمل جميع
القطاعات وخاصه القطاعات الحيويه مثلا
بالنسبه للقطارات اذا ما توقفت بالكامل
وليس جزء منها مثلا بالنسبه لليوم تقديم
عرض افضل له هؤلاء المدربين همم
في قطاع النقل بسكر الحديد ولكن سيتم
مراجعه هذه همم هذه همم يعني همم تم
تقديمه طيب من تحسين العروض ل همم
هؤلاء
العاملين بالعوده الى العمل بشكل يعني همم
في الوقت الحالي في ظل بان الحكومه
نعم ساكتفي بهذا القدر للاسف مصطفى انتهى
الوقت مصطفى زارو من لندن شكرا جزيلا لك
على كل هذه المعلومات
اخيرا غمرت مياه الفيضانات الطرق في اكبر
مدينه في نيوزيلندا وهي اوكلا فيما وصل
عدد الضحايا جراء تلك الفيضانات الى اربعه
اشخاص على الاقل
وقد بلغت كميه المتساقطات من الامطار في
اوكلاند وحدها
249 ملم وهو رقم قياسي جديد وما تزال حال
الطوارئ مفروضه في المدينه التي تضم واحد
فاصل سته مليون نسمه
[موسيقى]
نشاط الخامسه من العربيه انتهت اطيب
التحيات والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته